hello and welcome to bashiki science
show where as requested
in this video i'm going to talk about
the latest paper in vivo based editing
rescues hutchinson guildford progeria
syndrome in mice
where as you can see they were able to
extend the median lifespan
of the mice from 215 days to 510 days
more than doubling their median lifespan
and so in this video firstly i'll talk
about what is hutchinson's guilford
progeria syndrome
and how was it caused and how base
editing can be employed to treat this
condition
also going into detail about what
actually is base editing
and then we'll take a look at the data
in this paper and then leave us some
further questions and thoughts
so firstly then what is hutchinson
guildford progeria syndrome
which i'll refer to as progeria from now
on well
it's a very rare genetic disease that's
characterized by accelerated aging
people with this condition look healthy
at birth but from around the age of one
symptoms begin to emerge beginning with
growth failure skin abnormalities and
hearing loss
but progressing rapidly into joint
stiffness loss of fat under the skin
musculoskeletal abnormalities and
wrinkles
and sadly for these reasons patients
with progeria
typically die aged around 14 or 15 due
to atherosclerosis severe cardiovascular
complications or stroke
now the majority of patients with
progeria have genetic mutations
in the gene lamin a well the majority
seem to have the same
one mutation in lamin a which is a
mutation of a cytosine residue
to a thymine residue and so the gene
laminae encodes the protein laminae
and lamins are a set of proteins that
can be found in the nucleus
and they can mainly be found interacting
with the inner nuclear membrane
they play a really important role in
maintaining the integrity of the nucleus
but lamins are not just required for
structural integrity
due to their mechanosensitive properties
it's also now thought that lamins play a
key role in the regulation of gene
expression
so what happens to laminae in progeria
patients
well progeria patients have that single
mutation as i mentioned
and that mutation is an exon 11 so it's
an encoding region of lamin a
as in a region of the gene that will
actually end up coding for the protein
so in terms of how the codon is affected
the change goes from
ggc to ggt so both of them still
code for glycine so you might be
thinking well that doesn't affect the
protein it's a synonymous mutation
however something very interesting
happens with this mutation
the change from cytosine to thymine
introduces
a splice site and so it's actually
referred to as a cryptic splice site
and so what happens is the cell reads it
as a splice site
and cuts off parts of exon 11 so it
doesn't end up in the final
mrna product and so part of the coding
sequence is missing
and within that sequence is a cleavage
site and so
what happens is the processing of lamin
a becomes put up
and so instead of forming laminae you
start from pre-lamin and you
end up with this alternative protein
product that is referred to as progerian
now that felt like a bit of a
long-winded explanation so here is a
nicer diagram than my sketches
from the nature news and reviews article
that might make
a bit more sense but the bottom line is
that the presence of progerian is bad
because it hampers the activity
of the normal laminae and so it perturbs
the nuclear shape
rigidity and function and this is
deleterious for a cell
and cells that are particularly
vulnerable are cells found
in the skin and the cardiovascular
system because they're more exposed to
mechanical stress
which without the functional laminae
cannot cope with
and it's interesting to note that the
presence of progerian
has also been shown to be a biomarker of
cellular aging in human skin
and so understanding this disease itself
and how it manifests
is one area that's really interesting
but obviously the important question is
what kind of therapeutics are available
to be able to deal with this
well a variety of attempts have been
made there was some interest in using
metformin
and other more advanced drugs include
those that inhibit an enzyme
known as cell transferase that modifies
progerian and aids in its accumulation
and one of these ionopharnib was
approved by the fda
just last year however one of the more
obvious suggestions to be able to treat
this disease is to be able to target the
genetic mutation itself
but whilst it may be obvious it is not
trivial
however a series of studies came out in
2019
that used crispr cast 9 genome editing
to repair the lamin a mutation
both of these studies were effective in
terms of alleviating the decline in
health in mouse models of progeria
however translating this directly to
human patients isn't so easy
due to the concerns with using crispr
cast 9. you see crispr cas9 uses the
enzyme cast 9
that is a nuclease that induces a
double-stranded break into dna
so this is effectively a form of dna
damage firstly due to the nature of the
way crispr cas9 works by using a guide
rna to target the complex
to different regions of dna it can
result in
the complex being recruited to so-called
off-target sites
and there it could also be inducing
double-stranded breaks
and so this could be deleterious for the
cell i make it prone for tumor genesis
now don't get me wrong crispr cast 9 is
a really useful technique
and was well worthy of the nobel prize
this year but what's more interesting
is that the cas9 protein itself can get
mutated
so that it only cuts one strand on none
of the strands
and so this reduces the chance of there
being double stranded brakes
and so it's thought that these
approaches that have mutated
nikkei's or dead cast 9 versions are
much safer
in terms of using it for treating
different human diseases
however the thing is the efficiency of
editing massively decreases without a
double-stranded break
because in the traditional crispr cast 9
model you need that double stranded
break to open
up the genomic region which enables a
repair template
to come in and access the region and
enable precise genome editing
this is much more challenging with a
single cut or no cuts at all
and so this is where base editing comes
in so base editing doesn't need a repair
template
nor does it need a double stranded break
and so as given by the name
base editing edits bases and so to be
to be a bit more specific base editing
can edit
the different nuclear bases and so this
is simply the four different nuclear
bases which you likely have heard of
a t c and g adenine thymine guanine and
cytosine
and so far there are two main base
editors there are adenine-based editors
and cytodemas editors
adenine-based editors convert adenine
through an intermediate called inosine
to guanine so you go from an a to a g
cytosine based editors on the other hand
converts a cytosine
through an intermediate known as uracil
to thymine
so you go from c to t and so in progeria
patients
the ideal goal would be able to change
this thymine residue back to cytosine
now there's no such thing yet as a refer
cytosine based
editor so the alternative approach is to
use an adenine based editor because
thymine pairs with
adenine in the dna and so if you think
about it in terms of the dna structure
you can edit that thymine residue back
to cytosine if you edit
the adenine residue to guanine because
guanine then pairs with cytosine as it
as any base editors then
are a fusion of the cas9 protein with a
deoxy adenosine deaminase
that can convert the adenine into
inosine which is effectively rises
guanine within a cell
and then after dna replication you get
the changing from
an original a to t base pair to a g to c
base pair so therefore it has the
potential to fix the mutation seen in
progeria patients
so this nicely brings us on to this
recent nature publication
where they actually used quite a fancy
adenine base editor
that's been modified to improve its
efficiency in terms of
the ammonite activity but also possess
a variant that enables it to target a
special palm site
a protospacer adjacent motif that
enables
the base editor to get close to the
target sites on the laminae gene
so firstly they tested their system on
fibroblast cells that were derived from
patients with progeria
and they delivered the system by
lentiviral infection
so it results in stable expression of
the adenine base
editor along with the guide rna to
target it to the lamin a site
and impressively they observed very high
efficiency
of editing up to 91
by 20 days in one of the cell lines and
the remarkable thing about the editing
is that
it's also evident in the nuclear
morphology so as i said before the
laminae is really important for
maintaining nuclear
structure and so in progeria patients
it's common to see a kind of wrinkled
nucleus
which basically shows that the nucleus
has been deformed and isn't
as it should be however as you can see
in this figure here
with the addition of the adenine base
editor the morphology is restored along
with
a reduction in progerian expression and
a nice circular pattern of expression
for lamin a
and the other good news is that any of
target editing was very low
less than 0.1 percent in these cell
lines supporting the potential safety of
using this adenine-based editor
for editing the lamin gene so the next
step was to test this approach
in vivo by delivering the adenine-based
editor
to a mouse model of progeria whereby
they actually have the human progeria
mutated gene being expressed
so to deliver the genes that express the
adenine based editor
and the guide rna into the mice they use
the fda approved delivery system of the
adeno-associated virus
the thing with these viruses is that you
can't really pack too much into them
and castline is quite a big protein so
they actually have something very clever
here which is to split
up and have two separate aavs
adeno-associated viruses well they
actually split up the
adenine-based editor complex and used in
teens that then
in fivo bring the complex back together
very awesome by chemistry
um a bit tmi for this video but alas
i mentioned that anyway now it's too
late anyway the main aim of using this
delivery system
is to try and get the adenine base
editor to as many cells as possible
of particular importance cells in the
heart and muscle
that as i mentioned earlier are
particularly relevant for progeria
patients since they're the ones that
receive a lot of mechanical stress
and so that is another reason why they
chose the adeno-associated virus
in particular the aav9 virus because it
has quite a broad tropism
so it targets lots of different tissues
and the actual mechanism of delivery
that showed the most promise in these
results was via retro-orbital injection
and this was done
when the mice were either three days old
or two weeks old
and as you can see here in both cases
different tissues were targeted by the
virus
resulting in expression of the
adenine-based editor
and correct editing of the the lamin a
gene
in particular you can see quite high
editing in their liver but notably in
the
two week injection you get a higher
editing efficiency of the aorta and bone
tissue
so the base editor was working in fivo
but did this have any impact on the
phenotype of progeria in the mice
now if you do remember what i said at
the beginning a common cause of death of
progeria patients is atherosclerosis
and that's due to the hardening of the
blood vessels and so if you can see in
these figures here
you can see that by six months of age
progeria mice that were given the
adenine base editor
have a much reduced diameter of this
fibrous staining that you can see
around these vessels here and along with
this improvement
in aorta pathology was also the
remarkable extension of
median lifespan that i spoke about at
the start of the video
which i think you'll agree is very
striking and impressive
as the median survival increased from
215 days up to 510 days
and 510 days actually corresponds
roughly to the beginning of old age in
this type of mice
but as you can also notice some of the
mice did die and it's important to
understand what was the cause of that
death was it due to progeria or due to
the treatment
and out of the nine that died five of
them had liver tumors
and so they looked to see if there was
any aav integration into the liver
and they found that in the aav injected
mice but not from the control mice there
was evidence of rare aav
integration into genomic regions where
integration has previously been
associated with liver tumors and mice
and so see that's a cause of concern for
translating this therapy to humans
however so far there hasn't ever been
reported liver tumours from humans
treated with therapeutic aav factors
and so one potential way of reducing the
risk of this happening at least in the
mice
is to use lower doses of aav and one way
that they
could use lower doses is if they have a
more efficient
as a name based editor and so since this
work was actually done there has been
adenine-based editor variants that have
even higher editing efficiencies than
the one that they used in the study and
so potentially by using these more
efficient
editing adenine based editors they might
be able to reduce the required dosage
and may also therefore be able to
prevent
or reduce the risk greatly of liver
tumors from forming but besides the
dosage the other important consideration
is the timing of the injection it's kind
of remarkable here that they just had a
single injection and they saw this
phenotype
of their lifespan extension it'd be
important to work out what is the most
effective time to give it to
progeria patients given also the fact
that there's
a bit of a delay in terms of actually
diagnosing the disease in the first
place
and so safety is paramount but this work
is definitely a step forward
in the therapeutic treatment of progeria
so with that i just have one final thing
to say which is i think i have finally
launched the patreon page
absolutely no pressure i don't really
expect anything just there if you want
to
and i'll also be uploading at least from
now the maps for
each of my videos so with that i hope
you've learned something and as always
thanks for listening